[Aplausos]
[Música]
pensábamos que nunca viviríamos una
guerra en pleno Siglo 21 como es esto
posible lo sé todo el mundo ha dicho
esto en algún momento de las últimas
semanas todo el mundo pensaba que Las
Guerras eran cosa del pasado parecía que
el espíritu pacifista de John Lennon nos
había poseído a todos los europeos
incluido a Vladimir Putin pero recordad
a todos John Lennon le llega su Yoko Ono
y el momento Yoko en europeo ha sido la
invasión de Ucrania de repente el
consenso antimilitarista en la Unión
Europea ha desaparecido entramos en una
nueva era con noticias como ésta
Alemania va a aumentar el gasto militar
en un giro histórico prácticamente todos
los gobiernos europeos están haciendo
anuncios similares y si esto es todo un
giro copernicano en la Unión Europea
porque Europa lleva décadas gastando muy
poco dinero en defensa y cuando digo muy
poco dinero quiero decir menos de lo que
deberían según Los acuerdos de la otan
según la carta fundacional de la otan
todos los estados miembros deberían
gastar al menos un 2% de su producto
interior bruto en velocidad Sin embargo
atentos a este mapa
[Música]
los países que aparecen en rojos son los
que no cumplen con los compromisos de la
otan como podéis ver salvo Francia
Polonia y unos pocos más casi nadie Los
cumple y así ha ocurrido desde hace casi
30 años por si alguien se lo preguntaba
No el coronavirus no tiene nada que ver
con esto básicamente tras la caída del
telón de acero todos los países europeos
han reducido en términos relativos sus
presupuestos de defensa año tras año
conclusión Europa no está preparada para
resistir un posible ataque de Rusia y
todo esto explica por qué Vladimir Putin
se ha atrevido a impedir Ucrania
mientras esperaba que Europa se quedara
mirando de brazos cruzados Así que la
pregunta ahora es de dónde va a salir
todo ese dinero para financiar tantísimo
gasto militar puede ser esto una
oportunidad Dorada para las empresas
europeas Hasta qué punto La amenaza de
Putin puede ser toda una oportunidad Sí
sí una oportunidad única para que Europa
deje de estancarse económicamente hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a hablar de defensa pero de
defensa de nuestro ordenador o de
nuestro teléfono móvil como ya sabéis
internet está lleno de hackers y hackers
de todas partes del mundo y una buena
forma de evitar buena parte de estos
hackeos es usando una VPN y cuál es la
VPN favorita de visualpolitik Exacto
surfshark VPN creedme el tema de la
ciberseguridad se lo toman muy en serio
por ejemplo Sur Shark tiene una
herramienta que se llama cleanweb que
bloquea todos los popups de propaganda
por donde se cuelan todos esos Bots y
cookies que francamente no queremos
tener Pues si todo esto fuera poco con
una única cuenta de Surfer VPN podrá
registrar todos los dispositivos que
quieras quieres navegar con seguridad
desde tu teléfono móvil desde tu
ordenador portátil o desde tu Smart TV
pues puedes hacer todo eso con una única
cuenta de surfshark VPN Y por supuesto
tenemos una oferta muy especial para
todos vosotros que seguís visualpolitik
básicamente si utilizáis el código
politik terminado en K podéis disfrutar
de un 83% de descuento más tres meses
extra totalmente gratuitos no esperéis
más creo que la situación actual ya nos
está enseñando una valiosa elección más
vale prevenir que curar y descargaros
los links que encontraréis en la
descripción y ahora Aquí vamos a ver un
poco de historia
[Aplausos]
cuando éramos pacifistas
en el año 2018 Donald Trump amenazó con
sacar a Estados Unidos de la otan y
haber cumplido su amenaza la otan se
habría desintegrado en ese momento y
creedme muchos otros líderes mundiales
En aquel momento lo habrían celebrado
por aquellos años el presidente francés
Emmanuel macrón llegó a decir que el
estado de La otan era de muerte cerebral
en estos momentos Supongo que macron
estará Deseando que nadie le recuerde
sus palabras pero hay que reconocer que
en ese momento preciso en el año 2018
Trump sí tenía una parte de razón ya
sabéis que aquí en visualpolitik siempre
fuimos muy críticos con la
administración de Trump pero en este
aspecto concreto hizo una llamada a la
atención muy importante casi ningún
miembro de la otan estaba cumpliendo con
sus compromisos de gasto militar a fin
de cuentas Por qué iban a hacerlo todos
sabían que en caso de amenaza contaban
con el apoyo del Tío Sam Por ejemplo en
este gráfico podéis ver el gasto militar
en Alemania
si os fijáis en los años 60 Alemania
gastaba casi el 6% de su pib en defensa
Durante los años 70 y 80 ese gasto fue
bajando hasta llegar al 2,56% en 1990 y
justo a partir de 1990 es decir cuando
cae el talón de acero baja
dramáticamente hasta quedarse en poco
más del 1%, y la misma tendencia se
puede ver en casi todos los demás países
de Europa a estas alturas la pregunta
que todos os estaréis haciendo es por
qué de repente todos los europeos se
dieron la mano y se pusieron a cantar el
Imagine de John Lennon mientras
arrojaban sus armas al mar pues no
exactamente pensadlo bien para qué se
creó la otan porque Estados Unidos
gastaban tanto armamento en los años 80
pues muy sencillo porque había una
amenaza real la de la unión soviética
sin embargo con la unión soviética
disuelta para qué había que gastar más
en armamento no os equivoquéis Europa ha
tenido guerras recientes por ejemplo los
millennials que veáis este vídeo habéis
vivido al menos una guerra la de los
balcanes guerra en la que por cierto
terminó participando la otan sin embargo
la guerra de los balcanes no había
ninguna gran superpotencia con bombas
nucleares envuelta las grandes guerras
tradicionales parecían una cosa del
pasado y tras el 11 de septiembre el
nuevo enemigo número uno del mundo libre
pasó a ser el terrorismo de repente los
malos de la película dejaron de ser
señores como este a ser señores como
este otro y durante todo el siglo XXI
todos los foros de defensa empezaron a
hablar de nuevos conceptos como lucha
antiterrorista ciberseguridad o guerra
híbrida
[Música]
créeme si os digo que esto no es una
opinión nuestra atentos a esta encuesta
aquí podéis ver como en el año 2021 la
principal prioridad militar en Europa
era el norte de África seguida de
oriente medio pensadlo bien luchar
contra una banda como al qaeda o el daes
es todo un desafío pero es un desafío
barato no hace falta portaaviones ni
submarinos nucleares que es lo realmente
Caro en un ejército dicho de otra forma
que muy pocos pensaban que fuera
necesario el gasto militar de hecho
incluso algunos se atrevían a decir
auténticas barbaridades como estas Pedro
Sánchez sobre el Ministerio de defensa y
falta presupuesto contra la pobreza
habéis oído bien para quien no lo
conozca Pedro Sánchez es el presidente
del gobierno de España en la actualidad
sí es verdad que dijo esta frase cuando
todavía era candidato para las
elecciones pero sirve para ilustrar el
sentimiento general en toda Europa
Durante los últimos 20 años los
gobiernos europeos no Solo han reducido
el presupuesto militar además han usado
el ejército para tareas que tiene muy
poco que ver con la defensa por ejemplo
en el año 2005 España creó la unidad de
emergencias militares que es una especie
de de bomberos que se paga con el
presupuesto de defensa y hay unidades
enteras que han dejado de entrenarse
para el combate y han pasado a hacer
tareas humanitarias ojo Esto no es una
crítica a la labor humanitaria ni a los
cuerpos de rescate ya sabéis que aquí en
visualpolitik tenemos un respeto sagrado
por las fuerzas armadas pero los hechos
son claros
casi toda Europa se ha tomado la defensa
como si fuera una broma incluso Hemos
llegado a ver propuestas tan
descacharrantes como esta hacia una
política de seguridad y defensa a prueba
del cambio climático una ruta de acción
para la Unión Europea sí habéis oído
bien en algún momento alguien en
Bruselas se le ocurrió que el cambio
climático Debería ser una prioridad en
el ejército y a ver no me
malinterpretéis aquí no estamos diciendo
que el cambio climático no sea
importante pero en caso de guerra o sea
de verdad hace de un esfuerzo imaginaos
ahora en Ucrania a alguien comprando
balas para sus metralletas y diciendo
oiga pero me las pone que sean
biodegradables dicho de otra forma
durante 30 años toda Europa estaba
convencida de que ya no existiría más
guerras suena ridículo pues seamos
honestos Sí suena ridículo ahora pero si
hubiéramos publicado Este vídeo Hace
tres semanas muchos nos acusaríais en
los comentarios de alarmistas Sin
embargo todo esto ha cambiado Putin ha
enterrado a John Lennon y también a Yoko
Ono como Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
si quieres La Paz
prepara para la guerra
lo hemos dicho varias veces en los
últimos días Putin ya ha perdido la
guerra da igual lo que ocurre en Ucrania
porque el objetivo de Vladimir Putin era
acabar con La amenaza de la otan durante
años parecía que realmente se iba a
salir con la suya sin embargo la
invasión de Ucrania lo ha cambiado todo
atentos las neutrales Suecia y Finlandia
reconsideran la idea de entrar en la
otan Y esto es solo el principio los
países bálticos ya han pedido a Estados
Unidos que ponga bases militares en sus
países y no Esto no es que Estados
Unidos haya dicho Oh me gustaría poner
una base militar en Estonia no ha sido
el propio gobierno de Estonia el que ha
dicho por favor poned bases militares
porque tenemos miedo de ser los
siguientes después de Ucrania Alemania
ya ha dicho que va a duplicar su gasto
militar pero no solo eso el canciller
Alemán olapsols ha llegado a decir que
quiere cambiar la Constitución para
incluir el gasto de defensa del 2% del
pib En otras palabras que hemos pasado
de escuchar a John Lennon para ponernos
a escuchar a sabato
[Música]
la pregunta ahora es quién va a pagar el
concierto porque sí es muy fácil decir
gastemos más en defensa Pero qué
significa eso vamos a comprar más
aviones contratar más soldados Pues
atentos
un estudio apunta que el ejército alemán
sigue sufriendo escasez de recursos el
informe del que hablamos No es un
informe cualquiera es un informe
encargado por el parlamento Alemán donde
se llega a decir que ninguno de los
submarinos y cazas de combate alemanes
está o estaba listo para el combate
todos ellos están o estaban en
reparación o ni siquiera tenían
combustible para zarpar dicho de otra
forma que si Rusia hubiera atacado en
ese momento no habría forma de responder
al menos hasta varias semanas después
Y esto no es algo único de Alemania
básicamente casi todos los ejércitos
europeos tienen el mismo problema el
poco armamento que tienen está guardado
en hangares Por qué Pues porque mantener
un caza de combate para que esté listo
para el combate es caro muy caro y sin
dinero no hay nada que hacer Pues bien
es muy probable que esta sea una de las
primeras prioridades de Europa lo que
llamaríamos el alistamiento por supuesto
también cabe esperar compras de material
nuevo os acordáis de los cazas f-35 de
los que tantas veces hemos hablado aquí
en visualpolitik Pues todo apunta a que
vemos muchos más f-35s en los ejércitos
europeos no se equivoquéis Esto no se
debe a la presión de Estados Unidos Esto
se debe a que tras décadas de
presupuestos raquíticos en defensa
Europa tiene muy pocas empresas de
armamento que realmente puedan competir
con las americanas Así que a día de hoy
si quieres un caza de combate de último
modelo no te queda otra que comprar el
f-35
pero esperad un momento porque ya sé lo
que estaréis pensando mucho Sobre todo
Vosotros los que hayáis llegado a este
vídeo desde la comunidad de asuntos
militares que ya sé que sois muchos por
fin nos escuchan Pues sí tenéis razón
por fin os escuchan pero aquí viene la
pregunta que todavía Nadie se está
haciendo de dónde va a venir todo el
dinero para financiar todo esto pensadlo
así la lista de prioridades urgentes
debido a un muerte y emergencias
existenciales en Europa es más larga que
nunca hace dos años tuvimos el cómic 19
que se tradujo en más impuestos y más
deuda la receta para salir de la crisis
del covid ha sido esta nueva agenda
verde para acabar con la emergencia
climática traducción más impuestos y más
deuda Ahora resulta que también tenemos
La amenaza de Rusia que se traducirá en
efectivamente más impuestos y más deudas
Y si a esto le sumamos la inflación
Nacho vidaliana que ya estamos sufriendo
y que todo apunta que vamos a seguir
sufriendo Durante los próximos meses
tenemos un panorama bastante sombrío
para los europeos Así que la pregunta es
que se puede hacer Pues aquí vamos
tener una idea
matar dos pájaros de un tiro
por qué no hay un Google europeo sí nos
hemos hecho esta pregunta un millón de
veces aquí en visualpolitik y seamos
claros Este es el problema de Europa sin
Innovación ni empresas punteras no hay
crecimiento económico que valga y sin
una economía que funcione no hay gasto
social ni lucha contra el cambio
climático ni mucho menos gasto en
defensa La pregunta es por qué Por qué
Europa siempre se queda atrás en todas
las nuevas revoluciones tecnológicas
internet redes sociales Inteligencia
artificial alguno dirá es que Europa
tiene impuestos muy altos pero realmente
si nos ponemos a comparar país por país
Estonia no tiene impuestos más altos que
California por ejemplo seguridad
jurídica Pues es que Europa tiene
seguridad jurídica Pues bien una de las
muchas razones que explican la falta de
innovación en Europa es el ejército
[Música]
sí lo habéis escuchado bien el ejército
o mejor dicho la poca inversión en las
fuerzas armadas por supuesto No es la
única razón ni tampoco quizás la más
importante pero sí es relevante pensando
bien tanto Israel como Corea del Sur
como los propios Estados Unidos son
países tecnológicamente avanzadísimos en
buena medida gracias a su ejército
silicon Valley nació Gracias entre otros
motivos a que el ejército estableció
justo ahí un centro de desarrollo de
telecomunicaciones
[Música]
de hecho internet el propio internet
nació como un proyecto de defensa de
Estados Unidos y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos en serio desde cuándo el
estado puede promover la i+d de forma
efectiva todos lo sabemos cada vez que
un gobierno quiere desarrollar una
tecnología concreta fracasa
miserablemente lo vemos todos los días
sin ir más lejos en la Unión Europea con
programas como por ejemplo el Horizon
europe que se dedica a financiar
proyectos de investigación sobre el
papel es una idea fantástica pero no
queréis investigarlo a fondo porque por
ejemplo os voy a dar un ejemplo real que
hemos podido ver personalmente desde
visualpolitik no voy a dar nombres pero
creedme si os digo que esto es un caso
real
[Música]
en el año 2018 una universidad europea
desarrolló un sistema para crear prensas
de biomasa prensas fáciles de construir
que permitían comprimir basura y
convertirla en pellets que generasen
energía de forma muy eficiente la
investigación era tan buena que llegó a
recibir un premio nacional el problema
El problema es que han pasado cuatro
años desde la finalización de este
proyecto Y todavía está por ver si algún
día se construirá una prensa de biomasa
basada en los diseños de este proyecto
ni siquiera se ha llegado a sacar una
patente que pueda comprar una empresa
cualquiera es un bonito taco de papel
que está en una estantería en algún
lugar de Bruselas porque a fin de
cuentas quién se va a molestar en
convertir esa nueva tecnología en un
producto realmente Útil para la sociedad
nadie por qué Pues porque nadie tiene el
incentivo para hacerlo y como este hay
mil ejemplos más
[Música]
Lágrimas de militar en cambio es
bastante diferente en este caso los
propios estados tienen un incentivo muy
grande para crear armas con las que
competir con el enemigo Así que la hay
más de ese canaliza sobre todo ha
propuestos aplicados Por supuesto que
también hay grandes sobre costos en la
i+d de defensa Ahí está por ejemplo el
f-35 del que hemos dado buena cuenta
aquí en visualpolitik pero Incluso en
este caso el resultado final es el caza
de combate más letal del momento
[Música]
es caro sí es tremendamente caro pero es
un arma que no tiene rival al menos
rival que se conozca y muchas de las
tecnologías que se han desarrollado para
crear el f-35 seguro quedarán lugar a un
montón de startups para uso civil dicho
de otra forma gastar en defensa tiene
una utilidad civil por eso no sería nada
descabellado proponer que buena parte de
este nuevo gasto militar no venga de
nuevos impuestos sino de otras partidas
de gasto que se destinaban a la
investigación civil En otras palabras
que los mismos fondos que ahora van a
parar a proyectos civiles ahora pueden
ir a parar a proyectos militares que
tarde o temprano tendrán una utilidad
civil
es decir que el gasto militar en
Innovación tiende a ser mucho más
aplicado que el resto de partidas
públicas en i+d esta Precisamente es una
de las razones por las que Israel con un
gasto en defensa del 5,6% de su pib sea
también la nación de las startups en
este caso el ejército ha servido para
galvanizar la innovación en otros
sectores Así que puestos a gastar la i
más de militar puede cosechar mejores
resultados que otras opciones
Así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros veremos algún día nuevas
subidas de impuestos en Europa para
pagar gasto militar o todo este gasto
militar vendrá de otras partidas de
gasto Hasta qué punto La amenaza de
Rusia podría ser de verdad una
oportunidad de oro para que algún día
surja ese Google europeo que tanta falta
hace podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en
los comentarios y como siempre no
olvidéis Que aquí en visualpolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos Todas las semanas
así que suscribíos a este canal y dadle
a la campanita para no perderos
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un saludo y hasta
pronto
[Música]